I just went down the wrong route with
the wrong crowd drinking and just
fighting and stuff these days tyler
Markarian loves life and his new job
working for a poppin restaurant chain
but for years his path was one of
self-destruction I kind of hated life
and hate myself and everyone and just he
was drinking and all night he
depressants and the mixture got me a bit
violent at times after years inside a
young offenders institution Tyler has
turned his life around given an
opportunity to work for the brewery
company Green King the firm has agreed
to take on 50 ex-prisoners by the end of
this year we've gone into some of those
prisons our met some of the prisoners
and heard their stories and we want to
give people a second chance and we're
faced with an industry of a shortage of
chefs and the prisons have got a number
of people with kitchen skills and
qualifications and we can see it's of
mutual benefit for both parties with
around three-quarters of prisoners
reoffending within a year of their
release authorities see the route into
employment as crucial in helping break
that cycle the government is now making
it easier for many more offenders to
access work release schemes there are
obvious safety implications but the
Justice Secretary says offenders will be
strictly vetted before qualifying for
release it's really important that there
are tough risk assessments made of every
person that is going out or rotten to
make sure that they're suitable for it
that Public Safety does come first so
that we do go through those tests and
it's important that those tests continue
to be in place but the evidence shows
that the overwhelming majority of
releases on temporary license well over
ninety nine percent are fully complied
with Tyler says his days of criminality
are firmly behind him and he's arching
more companies to follow the example of
his employer and offer offenders a
second chance if someone's a drug dealer
that's been brought up knowing nothing
cows about that and not guy
by a family or good friends but hanging
around with a bad crowd and there going
side for that but they come out and they
can't get employed they've got nothing
left to do but to make the money on the
streets again so giving the job to them
will change their life and it's changed
your life yeah it definitely has more
than 500 companies are now actively
involved in programs offering work to
ex-offenders the government needs many
more to volunteer though if it's too
seriously dent the reoffending rate that
cost the country in excess of 15 billion
pounds a year mark white Sky News